If you're living your life
right, you've already finished
every episode of Jordan Blum and Patton
Oswalt's Hulu series "Marvel's MODOK."
Across 10 episodes, the show
brings viewers into the life
of the man described as comics' most iconic
Mechanized Organism Designed Only for Killing,
and draws the curtain back on his problematic
approach to finding a work-life balance.
This take on MODOK is a reimagining far removed
from his usual appearances in Marvel Comics.
Sure, there's cackling and a healthy
dose of super-science machinations,
but his villainous behavior is presented
less as an alien philosophy and more like
the pursuits of a guy in his 40s who's still
trying to make it as a stand up comedian.
MODOK might have noble intentions but
they're rooted in the same delusion
that turns otherwise capable adults into
starry-eyed monuments to arrested development.
"For the millionth time, it won't
work. You can't have it all."
"Yes I can — I'm very special."
His moral gradient is black and white:
There are good people, like MODOK's mom,
who told him that he was special.
Everyone else falls into the same
category as the bullies who beat him up.
Their behavior will need to be corrected.
"Hey, we're people!"
"Not to me!"
It's a flailing, simplistic worldview,
illustrated by MODOK's dramatic,
all-or-nothing way of dealing
with, well, literally everything.
Throughout the show's 10 episodes, MODOK
takes the baby steps appropriate for a
man of his head-to-leg ratio, thanks
in large part to his forced reckoning
with family life. Here's how "Marvel's
MODOK" wraps up, and what it all means.
As the series progresses, little by little,
MODOK makes a gradual transition towards
being a better father. He's still not great
in the end, but you know what? He's okay.
He dances with his son Lou at his bar mitzvah,
acknowledges his shortcomings to his wife Jodie,
and even elicits a positive emotion from
his daughter Melissa, which is difficult
when you're parenting any teenage girl, let
alone one with a dominant supervillain gene.
But MODOK is still haunted by the man he was
20 years ago, and in this case, it's literal:
the time-displaced MODOK from the past finds
his present self and reminds him of what he
wanted to be. Past-MODOK shows his older
self all of the futures that could occur:
deaths at the hands of every Avenger,
toilet heart attacks, and, presciently,
that one potential outcome that sees MODOK
become the ruler of a utopian, unified Earth.
"You're a supervillain. You hate the world!"
"No I don't. I just want to change it."
It's a strange setup that calls back to Doctor
Strange's Infinity War scenario of "one chance in
14 million for victory," with one dark difference.
In the Infinity War, Tony Stark has to come to
terms with how much of himself he'll sacrifice,
while MODOK can succeed only if he sacrifices
others -- specifically, the family that he worked
so hard to deserve. The key word there -- the one
that cemented the family's doom -- is "worked."
It's unavoidable that "Marvel's MODOK"
is going to be compared to Adult Swim's
"Rick and Morty," as they both have science
fiction elements, pop culture references,
and self-serving cartoon geniuses. So it's
fitting that a line from Rick and Morty can
sum up the general theme of MODOK season 1.
"The thing about repairing, maintaining, and
cleaning is, it's not an adventure. There's no way
to do it so wrong you might die. It's just work."
That's the conundrum at the center of "MODOK":
take the exciting, destructive, dramatic path,
or keep working at the day-to-day aspects
of life. It's the ol' "Kill Iron Man,
or clean your apartment" conundrum.
One option means that MODOK's mother
was right, and he's a very special
boy. The other means doing the work,
and, if his younger self is to be believed,
never becoming what he dreamed he would be.
Melissa's earlier attempts to teach her old man
how to take the subtle, effective route echo
through his decision, and MODOK stands at the same
proverbial fork in the road as every dad that's
ever thought about just getting in the car and
driving away from it all, with the slight addendum
of a dozen rockets being fired at his kids.
Then comes the flash forward: MODOK chose
the first option. Like Doctor Horrible before
him, MODOK has everything he's ever wanted,
at the cost of the lives of the people he loved.
Yes, he's keeping his younger self tethered
to a torture device, using his chronocrystal
facial bedazzling to look back on what he lost.
But wanting his family back doesn't mean that he
fixed the part of himself that threw them away to
begin with. Untold years and a few dozen Avenger
deaths later, and grand, dramatic gestures are
still MODOK's only approach to problem-solving.
Like the darkest possible iteration of Murphy
Brown, MODOK declares that he will have it all.
How that'll pan out remains to be seen. Series
co-creator Jordan Blum has hinted that
a second season is already planned out,
so fans should get excited for more "MODOK"
misadventures in the (hopefully near) future.
"Yeah, let's just get out of here."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero television shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.